one of the recipients of an email from
hunter biden is confirming its
authenticity
actually several emails and text
messages and shedding some new light on
the family's role in a business
arrangement
involving a chinese company senior
political correspondent mike emanuel is
in washington tonight with the very
latest good evening mike
brett martha good evening to you hunter
biden's former business partner on a
chinese energy deal tony babilinski
breaks his silence
unloading text messages emails and
documents he claims are about hunter
biden's overseas business dealings
and interaction with joe biden
in a may 19 2017 text message obtained
by fox news hunter biden apparently
tells his business associates quote
my chairman gave an emphatic no that
same day business associate rob walker
appears to respond to tony babilinski
quote when he said his chairman he was
talking about his dad
bobolinsky served in the navy in the
1990s and was brought on to lead a group
including hunter biden and joe biden's
brother jim
in a business deal with a chinese energy
firm he was also the primary recipient
of this may
2017 email which fox obtained last week
noting 10 percent of equity
for the big guy a newly revealed text
message shows bobolinsky was apparently
warned by business partner james gillier
don't mention joe being involved it's
only when you are face to face
i know you know that but they are
paranoid fox's hillary vaughn questioned
joe biden
in october 2019. do you stand by your
statement that you did not discuss
any of your son's overseas business yes
i stand by that statement
in a statement bobolinsky told fox news
quote i've seen vice president biden
saying he never talked to hunter about
his business
i've seen firsthand that that's not true
because it wasn't just hunter's business
they said they were putting the biden
family name and its legacy
on the line a may 17 2017 text message
hunter purportedly writes to his
colleagues
the chinese are coming to be my partner
to be partners with the bidens
bobolinsky adds quote i realize the
chinese were not really focused on a
healthy financial roi
return on investment they were looking
at this as a political
or influence investment babalinski says
there was a power struggle
and in june of 2017 hunter rants about
not wanting to sign over quote my
family's brand
my family's only asset to tony
babilinski
bobolinsky explains once i realized that
hunter wanted to use the company as his
personal piggy bank by just taking money
out of it as soon as it came from the
chinese
i took steps to prevent that from
happening bobolinsky says he will share
his information with the senate finance
and homeland security committees
separately fox news has learned the
subpoena of a laptop and hard drive
purportedly belonging to hunter biden
came in connection with a money
laundering investigation
according to documents obtained by fox
and verified by multiple federal law
enforcement officials who reviewed them
it is not clear the status of that
investigation or if it is directly
related to hunter biden
house speaker nancy pelosi did not
engage when asked about the former vice
president
today i'm sorry i'm not answering your
questions okay we're talking about the
corona virus
some republicans argue it's time for joe
biden to talk
the american people deserve some answers
here and he needs to be asked about it
at tonight's debate
there is a reference in a may 2017 text
message about the need to stress to
hunter
does he want to be the reason or factor
that blows up his dad's campaign
written before a campaign was launched
experts say potential legal issues could
be money laundering
tax evasion and failure to register as
foreign agents
in this case china brett martha
mike emanuel live in washington mike
thanks